il aura fallu un an de négociations le
soudan s'apprête à tourner le dos à 17
ans de conflit un traité de paix
historique vient d'être signé par le
gouvernement soudanais et les cinq
principaux groupes rebelles du pays une
étape fondamentale pour le soudan
déchirée depuis plusieurs décennies déjà
le pays a connu plusieurs échecs
d'accord le premier en 2006 au nigeria
et le second au qatar en 2010 le soudan
avait donc besoin de ce nouveau souffle
le rêve est devenu réalité après des
efforts considérables qui ont permis
d'arriver à un accord de paix entre le
gouvernement et le front révolutionnaire
soudanais pour saisir l'importance de
cet accord il faut comprendre le
contexte soudan une des régions les plus
touchées par le conflit et le darfour à
l'ouest du pays en 2003 le conflit
éclate entre le régime à majorité arabe
du président déchu rahmane el béchir et
des insurgés issus de minorités
ethniques qui estime être marginalisés
les tensions sont vives et la guerre
fait plus de 300000 morts et 2,5
millions de déplacés selon l'onu
en 2011 elle la rébellion s'étant à la
région du kordofan sud et du nil bleu
les violences n'ont pas commencé en 1989
avec l'arrivée d'omar el-béchir la
discrimination l'absence de partage du
pouvoir de partage de ressources
tout cela a commencé en 1956 juste après
l'indépendance
et après tout ce temps que nous ayons
enfin réussi à trouver des solutions à
ces problèmes est une véritable victoire
les gens sont contents pas seulement les
hommes politiques ou les groupes armés
mais également la société civile tous
ceux qui vivent dans des camps au
darfour et qu'ils ont une histoire
tragique
il faut dire que le soudan était sur la
bonne voie puisque cette dernière année
les violences avaient diminué
omar el béchir a été renversé par
l'armée sous la pression de la rue en
2019 et cet accord sont encore plus fort
car le procès de omar el-béchir aura
justement lieu le 1er septembre
mais que contient ce traité est bien les
rebelles et le gouvernement ont paraphé
8 protocole sur les thèmes suivants
entre autres le partage du pouvoir la
sécurité la justice et le retour des
réfugiés
autre point important de cet accord il
stipule que les mouvements armés seront
dément
clay et que leurs combattants devront
rejoindre l'armée régulière qui sera
réorganisé pour représenter toutes les
composantes du peuple soudanais
mais il reste encore du chemin à
parcourir deux factions rebelles ont
refusé de prendre part à l'accord mais
le gouvernement espère tout de même
pouvoir les convaincre de déposer les
armes